cigar aficionado has some prop bats and
some predictions it's there it's there
NFL issue and I was reading it and I saw
the Danny Sheridan the great odds maker
handicapper had some interesting takes
there on how to gamble this upcoming
season and knowing Danny a long long
time and just the and I I encourage
people if it's entertainment purposes I
used to be a heavy better and got out of
it thank God but if you do bet
Danny had some ideas for you some things
to do and don't also who he thinks will
be playing in this your Super Bowl in
Minnesota and Danny Sheridan joins us
Danny good to talk to you again thanks
for joining us good dear your horse
again Dan thanks for having me on okay
where do you want to start when it comes
to how to bet on the NFL the tips that
you gave in the magazine gave about six
or seven of them and I not - I'm not
getting paid to sell the magazine but
I'd suggest buying it it's a page 110
but I guess my biggest suggestion would
be if you wager on professional football
don't that parlays sucker bets and we'd
probably have to spend about the next 40
minutes discussing the rest of but if
there's any particular one you want to
discuss I'll be glad to but again don't
bet parlays what about rematches where
you have one team beating one team
earlier in the season and then the
rematch that's one of my favorites Dan
when let's say the Giants play Dallas
and they lose to Dallas at home always
in the rematch the team that beat the
spread the first time go against that
team in the rematch it really worked out
well last year I think it was plus 22
games which is very very high but and
the reason for that is the complacency
you beat a team at home your division
rival you're going to be complacent when
you get them at your place at least
that's the way I hand again what's a
great bet this year bet against New
England Patriots they were 16 and 3
against the spread last year it will be
overpriced starting with Kansas City and
I would wager against him against the
spread not to lose the game what about
winning the World Series
they are winning the winning the Super
Bowl I should say then we could get some
of the other sports but the Patriots the
overwhelming favor where can you make
some money where some smart money here
well first of all I would never bet a
future odds I like the Patriots again
along with the herd I picked them last
year and picking the Super Bowl winner
when there are 12 teams left in the
playoffs it's very difficult for me not
to mention preseason but I would not
recommend future bets I don't think
there's any money to be made doing that
what stuffer college or the pros depend
on pros without a doubt I really do well
in the colleges and the pros some years
are great some years are average and
some years I don't win but overall the
colleges to me or the they're just
beautiful love college football as you
do to Dan but what makes it easier to
pick a college sprint as opposed to the
NFL you have about 60 or 70 teams to
choose from versus 16 teams to choose
from and the colleges it's you know the
pros are like hey we're winning by eight
points or whatever we just run the ball
up the middle very boring colleges
they'll throw the ball Steve Spurrier
was a great example of that
you just never colleges are just I don't
know it's easier I say the most
important thing is the fact that you can
pick 60 or 70 games to choose from
versus 16 boring NFL games and but I
mean boring I mean with the point spread
because the point spread is very
accurate in the NFL it's I think I have
a little edge others do also early in
the college season because the
oddsmakers haven't adjusted everybody
seems to have a bad beat I'm around guys
all the time to tell me when they when
they won their bets but they never tell
me when they lose do you have a bad beat
story when it comes to the NFL or
college football oh god I had so many I
wouldn't know where to start out in
college football when I was shaking
everyone's hand in my office
congratulating myself on picking
northwestern plus I guess four or five
and they tried it out they tried they
kick the ball to Northwestern with a
couple of seconds ago they being I
believe Ohio State
long story short next thing I know how
State scores a touchdown that was a bad
thing and they've been plenty more I
might add to a damn when I win the lucky
ones when I get a bad beaten when the
lucky ones I consider that being an
expert the others bad luck who would you
bet on to win the MVP in the NFL I know
who you have is the favored Tom Brady
who would you put money on I would say
either Aaron Rodgers would be a good
choice at five-to-one
Green Bay is going to be very good this
year maybe Derek Carr at 7 to 1 wouldn't
do Brady because I think it's asking too
much for him have another sensational
year who are the surprise teams you have
this year because it usually you'll get
a couple to go up in a couple that go
down well when you say surprise teams
Dan to me a surprise team is one that
beats a spread I'm not I don't mean this
to be sacrilegious but I don't look for
surprise teams in the NFL unless going
to beat the spread
I see tremendous value and schlock teams
like jets and the 49ers and major
schlock in Chicago feel part of my I
have to clean it up here
what about World Series and that's going
to be excuse me Cleveland is going to be
another good one they're horrible but
they'll be they'll beat the spread
wait so if I'm going to bat let's say I
was going to bet on the Jets and the
Browns and the Niners this year against
the spread you think that's smarter you
have to pick your spot down I didn't
mean interrupt you you can't just bet
them every week you have to take like
let's say Pittsburgh is going to play
Cleveland you want to catch Pittsburgh
off of a big win and then you take your
spot these shock teams are very
underrated bookmakers know that the
public bets favorite so what do you do
you you inflate the line so you're
getting tremendous value anytime you
take the Jets the 49ers Buffalo Chicago
Jacksonville and so on we're talking to
Danny Sheridan a sports betting
handicapper analyst saw some of his
betting tips in this month's edition of
a cigar aficionado how do you become an
odds maker that's a good question I
guess you have to have a good opinion I
really can't answer that except I've
been lucky for about 35
five years there's no school then I
don't think you can go to school but you
said you bet I didn't realize that you
wagered on football when we were seeing
it I wish I had known that I would have
encouraged you to bed with me no I had a
bad beat and I think it was the Orange
Bowl and I lost half of the money that
I'd built up and I I just cashed out
that was it I was done I remember losing
on a bet remember Chester Marcol with
the Packers had a had an extra but he
had a field goal blocked against I think
the Bears and he caught it and ran it in
for a touchdown if he makes the field
goal I win my bet Chester Marcol gets it
blocked he picks it up he runs it in for
a touchdown
man let me say that that's definitely
Hall of Fame bad beat I have to put that
one and I had forgotten about that one
well I had at my former bookmaker and
out of Pittsburgh Toni Luczak Toni I had
a bad beat on the Saints with a
Dempsey's field goal against the Lions
he lost about 63 oh yes taunted em
through yeah yeah so he he I see that's
that's more entertaining than guys
telling me hey you know I won on this
but I want to know when you lose that
that's when you got better stories
they're not that anybody wants to tell
you but I I tell mine because I don't
bet anymore
you're correct though it's it's it's due
it's - well anyway betty let me say this
betting on pro football can be hazardous
to one's wealth i think but you bet a
lot
I don't know Dan that's the beauty of it
I do not bet I have never I don't bet on
sports and that's why I think I have a
decent opinion I think when you've been
on or chance a like Nick Saban I don't
like him look what he did doesn't bother
me if I'm if I miss a game it Nick's
David it's me all right we have a bat in
studio here with the dance then I have
one guy Fred C who says the Browns will
win at least five games this year
outright do you have any prediction on
the most happy book that I'll be excuse
me that I'll be most happy to book that
bit and when I win I'll give the
proceeds to charity we'll call five
attire
you're not going to win five games it's
possible but it's not probably Princeton
you should stick to what he does best
doing your show well that's what he does
best
I think so I don't know him personally
but seems to do a pretty nice job
princey do you want to bet Dany Sheridan
why not what do you want to bet him
you're already betting a you know a
wheel of punishment was seat me I think
it's great that he stepped up and he's
going to donate some money to to charity
if he browns well what about you you
don't know you lose would you donate
money to a chair I don't have that game
you don't have to you don't hey let me
just say this load up the wagon Fritzi
don't worry about this mule and I will
take you bed I'll give it to charity
and you can keep it if you win that's
extremely generous all right there you
go there you go like I'm glad to find a
charity to to donate to there's oh
there's all kinds of ways Yeah right I
don't know about us and let me say this
to you not to drop names but I used to
bet every year and I say I used to bet
we do it for charity Mike and Mike they
never beat me
I let him pick two Super Bowl teams I
laid them five and six to one on they
put up a hundred I put up six hundred
again they never beat me
now the question is will Fritzi beat me
Wow would you if I would you do this
though if I said you could have two
teams or the rest of the field for the
Super Bowl which would you take if I
said pick a side you're talking to be
damaged yes yeah oh no I'm done with
Fritzi
I'm sorry to hear that probably his
family is too I would take obviously the
chalk New England and I take Green Bay
if I had to pick two teams in the odds
are I'll be wrong on both of them but I
will let your staff pick any two teams
they want and I'll lay them six to one
money to go to charity okay who wants a
piece of Danny Sharon in here Seaton
geez all of a sudden are these the same
has not shot that I hear every day yes
yes yes that they're glammed up yeah
they are how about this Danny
let me let them think about it and then
I
they will collectively pick two teams
that they think will be
now it's just a win the Super Bowl yes
okay when the Super Bowl not be in it
correct okay
and it's all and say I'll a them five to
one I got to protect myself it will give
the proceeds to charity how's that okay
all right so we'll we'll take a brand
they get the bragging rights because go
greenie and goal you've never beaten me
so they get the bragging rights if they
win well now you're talking to real NFL
people that that's the difference here
between Mike and Mike that's why they
didn't last they couldn't handle the
pressure of trying to stand up to you
and they had to split them up you know
Golic said I got to have an NFL guy
brought in Trey Wingo to you know take a
piece of you I think that's that's how
that happened it's cigar aficionado
Danny's tips but also Danny Sheridan
calm is his website we were going to
come up with two teams here Danny and
then we'll wager that bet with you I
look forward in from Fritzie or you and
thank you Dan for having me on great to
talk to you again Danny thank you that's
Danny Sheridan the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience